president Trump steering clear politics
in his salute to America fourth of July
event yesterday on the National Mall
today we come together as one nation
with this very special salute to America
we celebrate our history our people and
the heroes who proudly defend our flag
the brave men and women of the United
States military as we gather this
evening in the joy of freedom we
remember that all share a truly
extraordinary heritage together we are
part of one of the greatest stories ever
told
the story of America it is the chronicle
of brave citizens who never give up on
the dream of a better and brighter
future to this day that spirit runs
through the veins of every American
patriot it lives on and each and every
one of you here today it is the spirit
daring and defiance excellence and
adventure courage and confidence loyalty
and love that built this country into
the most exceptional nation in the
history of the world and our nation is
stronger today than it ever was before
for Americans nothing is impossible a
Washington Post op-ed writer praised the
president saying quote Trump made his
critics look small during the salute to
America
unquote but 2020 Democrats they still
had some harsh words for the event it's
become a day where it's all about Trump
rather than about our country and our
freedoms and the vision that our
founders had for us I think it's a waste
of money you know he's having a parade
for himself putting tanks out there for
himself and if he really cares about the
men and women who are serving our nation
he'd be investing in higher pay better
housing better health care
I think we need money to go into
rebuilding our infrastructure I'm not
quite sure that we need money to go into
put tanks Donald Trump is handing out
tickets to his big donors that's
campaign of him and if he's going to do
a campaign event then it should be paid
for by his campaign contributions it
should not be paid for by the American
taxpayer in a corner this is my first
time on the five so so tell me what you
think did you see it of course I did I
actually was watching from an airplane I
was headed back from Charleston South
Carolina after doing our proud American
coverage there and feeling extra
patriotic on the heels of that anyway
but I felt like I was having a spiritual
experience and I think if you were an
American watching this and it didn't
matter how you felt about the president
before this speech it was beautiful it
was incredible and the critics that you
saw there the Democrats saying oh he's
just doing this for himself he's
throwing himself a parade he didn't say
anything about himself he spoke about
decorated military veterans he talked
about astronauts he talked about civil
rights leaders he talked about American
exceptionalism he put politics aside for
this I was impressed you remember when
he was on the campaign trail in 2016 and
he said I'm gonna be so presidential
when I want to be I'm gonna be boring
well he wasn't boring but he was
certainly presidential he left his
slings and arrows for a campaign rally
on another day and another time in place
and I thought it was very appropriate
had the perfect tone so Lawrence one of
the critics and one of the things the
critics did was to mock him for saying
the Continental Army was going to an
airport clearing out an airport I want
to give him the benefit of that I know a
lot of people didn't give Obama the
Bennett if it worked out when he said I
think he said 57 States when he was
campaigning but I'm gonna give the
president the benefit of the doubt that
you want but what did you think well I
think that his critics looked pretty
dumb yesterday all of them
that said that this was going to be a
Trump campaign rally have y'all been to
a Trump campaign that was nothing like a
trump campaign rally they talked about
multiple things the the crowd is much
morality or when it comes to the Trump
talks a lot about himself and not
America and his greatness as well and I
think the president showed that he was
willing to put politics aside and talk
about what's best for the country and
how to move forward a lot of people said
that it was born because he gave a
history lesson I think it's important
that we remember our history so we don't
repeat it as well there were some
critics that talked about the military
and the president flexing when it came
to showing our great military look this
is the president that has been very
restrained when it comes to military
force so if he wants to flex to show the
world this is how you defend freedom
this is this is what we have to offer I
think that is to be applauded instead of
sending our military into harm's way
alright so Tammy let me get serious with
you for just a sec oh yeah but Tammy you
saw there what Elizabeth Warren said
there you he didn't have his donors pay
for this event even though they had
reserved seating and tickets he could
have you know and I'm sure that some of
them would have paid for it instead it
was the u.s. Park Service that went you
know millions of dollars taken out of
their budget budget money that could
have gone to parks or to helping young
people go to visit parks what are you
happy what do you say to that well you
know I think that as you when you win
the presidency there there benefits to
that right you also invite people to the
White House who've supported you and are
your supporters that's part of the
natural process here the National Park
Service I think we had an estimate of
what about two to two and a half million
dollars nobody was clutching their
pearls in 2016 when the National Park
Service spent 30 million dollars for
their own 100-year anniversary and you
know that's but I think all of that's a
distraction I think what you've got here
are and when they were worrying about
the president talking about himself
there's only one group of people talking
constantly about Donald Trump and it's
the Democrats he is still in the
building mode he has condominiums in
their head and it's the most affordable
living situation Bernie Sanders wants
affordable living he's living in their
heads for free there is no
rent so this is I think there's a lot of
projection going on he is the center of
their universe you may disagree with
this but you have to admit they think
they're gonna win the presidency based
on obsessing about Donald Trump and as
they do and this is like maybe you've
even been changed a little bit about
with what happened yesterday they're
afraid that is the American people watch
something like that people are
transformed and realized that they've
been lied to for the last three years
about this man oh you think it you think
it really would persuade people who were
not proud from I think so because we've
already seen it I mean when people with
the Miller report as an example after
all this stuff was CNN and it was not
what they said it was going to be
already people have realized they've
been lied to about serious issues
they've retreated you know when it comes
to ratings and who they're listening to
and that's a sign that the American
people want the truth they want
information and they're tired of being
lied to
well I disagree because I think that
it's something that you know I love the
fourth of July and I just didn't want
politics broader but John you know what
you come welcome by the way the first
time we're sitting on this I know John
we love it and we're so grateful that
you came today so let me ask you because
in a way you know what John let's just
go beyond politics for a second
what did you think as a cultural critic
about the event was it something that
you enjoyed so our military the men and
women that serve in our military are not
Democrats or not Republicans or not
independence they're everybody right
that serves in the military so I think
honestly the president did a great
service to the military in respecting
that fact and not going into a partisan
angle when he was talking I watch the
entire thing and I kept waiting for him
to you know go hard to his to his base
or whatever and he never did it I mean I
heard everybody from Jackie Robinson to
John Glenn talked about in these
speeches and even for me these names
start coming up and you remember these
powerful powerful Americans and
entrepreneurs and great talents that
could only have succeeded like that had
they lived in our country and had a
military as strong as ours to protect
their right to become great baseball
players or astronauts or actors or all
the great people he was naming so I
thought he did a great job
by staying right on the message and to
me it was almost like a history lesson a
refresher course going through every
single branch of the military pointing
out great people that did great things
and then here comes the actual hardware
flying right over the top of the
Washington Monument you're what Wow I
mean I think for Americans if for me it
was a moment of pride to see all of that
come together in one moment and also I
think around the world they're watching
that going yeah they've got a lot of
they America is no joke and look at look
at look at how our principle of this
company of this country have developed
so many incredible Americans we I mean
we invented rock and roll we invented
country music we invented R&B we
invented the automobile all the things
he started reminding us of yes it
reminds you of how great our country
isn't it's great because it's free I
think I said I think he said Alexander
Graham Bell but the Canadians
immediately said I think but keep in
mind too that with this when you think
about what was the president going to do
he had a great speech at Normandy his
State of the Union addresses have been
universally praised this is not a
surprise and yes you've said he said I'm
gonna be presidential people continue to
underestimate him and this is why they
get blindsided is we're gonna make the
point I was just going to say that you
know it really deal agenda Mises the
panelists that they have on the other
cable networks when they come out with
the knives for Trump at a time when he's
clearly knocking it out of the park
right and I think of course we aired it
I was flipping back and forth between us
and CNN since it's part of my job and
going okay how are we covering how are
they covering it and I just I think they
really missed the mark they're grasping
at straws and trying to be negative
where's the money
just pay the money and then they'll shut
up about the money aspect of it because
it's really not about the money all
right